I feel it's my duty to bring these calls
between President Obama and president
like Trump directly to you the American
people here's the latest
oh very active year and that's electors
of the electoral college were faithful
to be so I got enough votes to be
President
yes I heard it's a shame I don't really
want the job what would you do first
no problem I'll call you back gotta go I
just saw the movie with the boat best
lady title ever what movie is that
fantastic where and where to find them
it speaks not breasts
oh I mean some of the boobs weren't bad
but not they're just you know they're I
gotta go I just wanted to reiterate that
I believe you avoid in this country I
was born in this country agreed of
calling you from Kenya
gotcha God's sake Donald that's none of
your business
my idea yells got something in Slovenian
that's what eyes these day I think it
means Oh God you're an animal
I love it I'm good women ma'am it means
I hate you hey bear I'm gonna be hanging
out Barlow go over the holiday so I
don't think I'll be talking to you much
until the new year
okay Donald have a good one you too bear
any last words before the year end yes
listen you and I don't see eye to eye on
a lot of things I'm quite frankly
doubtful you have the temperament to
navigate increasingly dangerous and
ever-changing global landscape Donald I
just hope that you reign in your
explosive personality late-night
tweeting and all that and please just
use the traditional tools of diplomacy
that are at your disposal and Donald I
know you say America first but I hope
that means American people first not
just American corporate interests okay
Donald you hear me
sorry no I got distracted by a really
funny pop-up ad that is world I think
I kept working on it tried to grab it
that but the little bags didn't get
grabbing him back there Barry are you
there
[Applause]
you